Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a comedy horror
film called “Mom and Dad.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
A family of four lives in a suburban American
town.
The parents, Brent and Kendall love their
kids but hate how their lives have changed
after having them.
Their youngest son, Josh is seven years old
while their eldest Carly is a teenager.
At the beginning of the movie, Carly is talking
to her boyfriend Demon on the phone.
Her parents do not like the guy, but Carly
of course doesn’t care.
She and Damon plan to meet later in the evening
when Damon is done with his final test at
school.
At breakfast, their housekeeper, Sunyi, listens
to the news about a mother leaving her infant
to die in a car accident.
Sunyi has brought her daughter Lisa to work
and they plan to leave after cleaning the
house.
The family is also expecting to see Brent’s
parents for dinner at night.
Carly wants to cancel the dinner to go out
with Damon which causes an argument between
her and Kendall.
Unknown to her mother, Carly has stolen hundred
dollars from her purse to hang out with her
best friend Riley.
Kendall drives her to school and they get
into yet another argument on the way.
Carly harshly tells Kendall that her life
is boring before getting out of the car.
Back at home, Josh playfully hits Brent with
his toy ball.
Brent looks at his son with murders in his
eyes but laughs it off.
However, we see him kick Josh’s toy car
before leaving.
The housekeeper Sunyi is pounding some chicken
while her daughter Lisa watches Josh play
in the background.
All of a sudden, Josh turns around to Sunyi
hitting her daughter with the Mallet.
Meanwhile, Kendall is out with her friend
and Riley’s mother, Jeanne.
They talk about Kendall’s sister Jenna who
is pregnant.
As Kendall goes through her purse, she notices
that her money is missing.
Jeanne claims that her daughter always steals
from her, hinting that Carly probably did
the same.
Carly is in her classroom when the teacher
gets a call asking him to send a kid to the
principal’s office.
Soon, he starts to get several calls and the
school is surrounded by cop cars.
Not thinking much of it, Carly and her best
friend Riley go to the washroom where Riley
complains about her mother being a bitch.
They buy some edible pills from a girl and
step out to see the school in complete chaos.
All the students are running around while
the teachers are nowhere to be seen.
They join the crowd and see a classmate’s
mother trying to cross the school’s fence.
Outside the school, a large crowd of parents
has gathered wanting to enter the premises
but the police and the security are holding
them back.
Not knowing what to do, one kid runs to his
mother who brutally stabs him with her car
keys.
The crowd goes wild as more parents start
to beat their kids brutally.
Some even kill them in the open.
Carly and Riley manage to get away from the
crowd and get inside Riley’s car.
Confused by what is going on, they drive to
Riley’s house.
Meanwhile, Carly’s boyfriend Damon is in
the examination hall.
There is still an hour left for the test to
be done but the parents of the students gather
outside waiting for them.
The invigilator thinks it’s weird but dismisses
the matter.
Damon gets done before everyone else and leaves
the hall.
Behind him, the parents run inside to meet
their kids.
Damon calls Carly telling her that the test
went great.
When he reaches home, he finds his father
drunk sitting on the sofa.
Not thinking much of it, Damon starts to clean
up the mess in the kitchen when his father
slaps him out of the blue.
At first, Damon dismisses it because he is
drunk but things get heated when his father
attacks him with a broken glass bottle.
As the two struggle, his father falls to the
ground and accidentally stabs his throat,
and dies.
At the same time, Kendall is in her car reminiscing
about her failed meeting with an ex-employer.
The man tells her that she has two kids and
has been out of work for over fifteen years
so they cannot let her in that easily.
Seeing what her life has come to, Kendall
starts to have a mental breakdown.
As she sobs, she gets a call informing her
that Jenna has gone into labor.
Kendall rushes to the hospital and sees a
crowd watching the news about parents killing
their children.
Before she can listen to it, she is called
by her sister.
Jenna gives birth to a healthy baby girl.
He holds her baby in her arms but the beautiful
moment turns dark when she starts to strangle
the baby and has to be restrained.
She even gets her hands on a pair of scissors
and tries to harm her daughter but Kendall
snatches the baby out of her grip and brings
her outside.
She cries hysterically asking the nurse what
is going on.
The nurse takes the baby to a safe zone, claiming
that all the parents have gone crazy.
Outside the neonatal ward, the fathers stare
at their newborns ready to attack them.
Carly and Riley finally reach Riley’s home.
Carly watches the news while Riley goes upstairs.
The news talks about a mysterious virus that
has spread across America that makes the parents
want to kill their children.
Carly starts to freak out and goes upstairs
looking for her friend.
To her horror, she comes across Riley being
strangled to death by her mother.
She panics and runs away from the house only
to come across a man with a bloodied baseball
bat.
Damon finds her in the streets and tells her
that she should stay away from her parents.
The couple then goes to Carly’s home to
look for Josh.
In the meantime, Brent is at his office taking
a nap.
He wakes up and asks his assistant to not
take calls from anyone.
Then, he looks at a picture of his kids and
screams, indicating that he also has been
infected by the virus.
Damon and Carly reach home and see that the
housekeeper Sunyi is still there.
They carefully walk inside and ask her where
Josh is.
The woman calmly replies that he is in his
room.
The couple gets a look at Sunyi’s mop that
is covered in blood and realizes something
terrible has happened.
Carly runs to get her brother while Damon
keeps an eye on the housekeeper.
Carly finds a terrified Josh under his bed
crying.
He claims that Sunyi did something really
bad to her daughter but doesn’t explain
what.
Sunyi drives away after cleaning the mess
but an infected Brent arrives right after.
He enters the house and sees Damon in the
kitchen.
As he orders him to get out of his house,
Josh hears him and gets out from under the
bed.
Carly asks him to run out quickly but Josh
insists on getting his backpack.
Brent is about to attack Damon but Josh calling
his name grabs his attention.
After seeing his kid, Bernt loses control
and attacks them.
Damon tries to save them but Brent knocks
him unconscious with a single punch to the
throat.
Following that, he trips on Josh’s toy car
giving Carly and Josh an opportunity to run
down to the basement and lock themselves.
They run down the stairs and see that everything
in the basement is destroyed.
Three weeks prior to the incident, Brent had
brought a pool table and built it in the basement
to turn it into a mancave.
He is pretty satisfied with his job until
Kendall sees the purchase and asks him how
much it cost.
Brent starts to yell at her saying that he
deserves to spoil himself a little bit because
he works hard.
As the two get into a fight, he brings out
a hammer and maniacally breaks everything
he just built.
He says that he wants to feel like his younger
and carefree self again but knows that is
not possible.
Kendall agrees, claiming that she sacrificed
her dreams and aspirations for her family
and although she loves everyone, she misses
her old self.
Back in the present, Kendall drives back home
while hoping her kids are okay.
She listens to the radio where the host warns
the parents to stay away from their kids because
one never knows when they might get infected.
Kendall quickly stops her car but it is too
late because she is already infected and has
reached her home.
She enters the house and joins Brent.
They bang on the basement door and ask the
kids to come out.
Kendall brings out an electric saw and tries
to break down the door.
At the same time, Brent goes to the other
room to get his gun but finds the gun case
empty.
Little Josh shoots his mother through the
door and the bullet hits her shoulder.
It turns out that Josh has stolen Brent’s
gun and kept it in his backpack a while ago.
Kendall makes her husband pour alcohol on
her wound.
Inside the basement, the kids hear their mother
scream in pain and cry.
Now, Kendall and Brent cannot enter the basement
forcefully with the fear of being shot.
Brent thinks of another way and attaches the
LPG pipe to the basement.
This way, they plan to gas the kids until
they pass out and attack them at the right
moment.
Kendall sticks tapes to cover the holes she
just created in the door so the gas wouldn’t
leak.
Carly notices this and pokes her fingers out
to investigate only to be attacked by her
mother again.
As the gas begins to fill up the basement,
Carly realizes what her parents are trying
to do.
A long time passes and Kendall and Brant patiently
wait for their kids to give up.
When they begin to cough because of the gas,
Carly devises a plan.
She finds a matchbox and carefully tears off
the box’s strip.
She then attaches it to the bottom of the
door along with some matchsticks.
This way, when the door opens, the matches
will light on fire causing an explosion because
of the gas.
Then, She and Josh get into a vent and crawl
their way out of the basement.
The parents realize that the kids have gone
silent, so they create a hole in the door
and look for them.
Following that, they open the door causing
an explosion.
Brent is gravely hurt but Kendall survives
and finds the kids in the hallways.
As she tries to kill them, they are saved
by Damon who happens to be alive.
He and Carly restrain Kendall and lock her
inside the closet but she manages to pierce
Damon’s cheeks with a hanger and breaks
free.
As the struggle continues, Kendall smacks
him with a mallet and pushes him off the railing.
Following that, Brant gains consciousness.
He and Kendall walk up to their kids to kill
them.
But before they can, the doorbell rings indicating
that Brent’s parents are here.
He opens the door for them but is immediately
attacked.
A chase ensues in the house, in which Brent
is chased by his father while he chases Josh.
At last, Brent and his father end up wrestling
inside a car.
Back in the kitchen, Kendall tries to persuade
Brent’s mother to not kill him, when she
doesn’t agree on doing so, she smacks the
old lady with the mallet.
She then moves to Carly and chases her outside.
The grandmother also follows them behind.
All of a sudden, the car that Brent is in
hits the grandmother, killing her.
The grandfather is thrown outside because
of the impact and is also killed instantly.
Brent, on the other hand, passes out because
of the crash.
As the others watch the scene, Damon, who
is still alive knocks Kendall out.
In the following scene, the parents are tied
in the basement while the kids watch them.
They try to fake being normal so the kids
would set them free but the trick doesn’t
work.
Josh tells his parents that he still loves
them.
The movie ends as Brent says he loves him
too, but sometimes he just wants to kill them.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.